from the eight news now investigators
the debate over a sock and a woman's
Freedom thank you for joining us at 11
I'm Brian Loftus I'm Denise Valdez now
that woman's
on a train bracelet setting off an alert
that could have put her back in jail 8
news now investigator David charns there
as a judge tries to figure out what
happened over the course of 20 hours
Taylor Madison's attorney said there was
really no way to prove what had happened
to that bracelet he said simply a sock
could have gotten in the way for those
20 hours the judge ended up calling this
interference Greg and Alexandra Johnson
sitting just feet away from the woman
accused of killing their 18 year old
daughter Kat the UNLV freshman dying in
this crash on the 95 outside Boulder
City in September police say Taylor
Madison was behind the wheel and
impaired a particular pair of socks in
court Tuesday prosecutors accused
Madison of tampering with her alcohol
monitoring bracelet she's out on bail
can't drink drive or use drugs
prosecutors say Madison violated the
terms of her release in December record
showing a judge warned her and increased
her bail but for nearly a day in early
March something triggered that bracelet
to issue a tamper alert medicine's
attorney asking a representative from
the company issuing those bracelets
about what could cause that that's an
example of that could be the socks goes
in between or whatever the case may be
judge Miller then viewing photos Madison
had reportedly taken of that sock her
attorney also saying the company
switched out the battery on the device
just a day later
[Music]
the judge agreeing there was no way to
definitively say the device was tampered
with but he gave this warning
this is three strikes
he's had a lot of leaning
throughout this process the Johnsons who
live in Tennessee say this was the first
time they saw Madison in person they say
they'll wait as the case takes its
course I just have to have faith in the
process and the judge and just hoping
that the final outcome will be what
we're happy with Madison remains out on
bail with that alcohol monitoring
bracelet and a drug monitoring patch a
preliminary hearing set for here in
Justice Court in June in Boulder City
I'm David Charles 8 News Now